this is Gustavo he's an international
student at Glasgow University living
with his wife and two daughters but
under new measures designed to lower
immigration his family wouldn't be
entitled to be here with him it's not
just about studying in and or walking
I also have my duties as a
as a father
so
I will not I I will not come if they
could not come with me
part of an effort to bring down the UK's
soaring immigration numbers that have
been causing problems for the Prime
Minister even overshadowing some of the
recent G7 Summit in Japan not helped by
his Home Secretary are you failing on
immigration until I get home true it's
been a tough time for the Home Secretary
she's been causing tensions firstly by
piling pressure on the prime minister to
bring immigration numbers down at the
same time she's been accused of breaking
the ministerial code over a speeding
ticket all this as new immigration
figures are about to come out that show
by its own standards her department is
failing today's announcement should go
some way to reversing the trend as in
2019 269
000 students with study visas brought an
additional 16 000 dependents last year
that number had rocketed to 486
000 student visas and 136
000 dependents
it's been welcomed by many conservative
MPS who say reducing immigration is
important to their voters but there is
concern among universities about which
students this could affect I think it's
clear that if anything that reduces the
ability to bring dependence is almost
certainly going to affect female
students for example we know that
globally women have greater care and
responsibilities so we really think that
the review process that has actually
been announced as part of this package
really needs to look at that what's the
impact on particular communities
back in Glasgow Gustavo is reflecting on
his time in the UK a reminder of the
people behind the policies Liz Bates Sky
News Westminster